hi there this is steve kaufman here uh
it's a saturday afternoon there's some
guy in my neighborhood who's got some
kind of a power
whatever it is blower or something
that's causing some noise you may or may
not hear
i'm not going to go over there and shut
him down although i'm tempted to do so
i guess he's allowed to do it
i want to talk today about
rrs
now no one has ever heard of rrs we know
of is it rss
whereby we pick up feeds from ipods very
handy when i manage to do it properly
uh then there's srs spaced repetition
systems
but i'm going to talk about random
repetition systems because i am not a
believer in spaced repetition systems
now i know this is going to generate a
lot of negative comment but i will
explain why
uh
i do
like
flash carding
and ever since we at link have got our
handy uh
ipod touch
app for flash carding i do them i enjoy
doing doing them
i think going through flash cards in
this way
where we have the word and we have the
captured phrase and it's kind of
easy to do
i think it's a pleasant thing to do
however i can't do it every day
maybe it would be good thing it would be
a good thing if if i did
but i don't and i don't feel any
obligation to do it every day so i
consider that my repetition
uh using these flash cards is
quite random and on that basis i enjoy
it i don't happen to believe
that the algorithm which says that i
should repeat it in 20 minutes and then
in two hours and then the next day and
the third day and the tenth day i just
don't happen to believe that
and i think it's very important no
matter what you do
that you believe in what you're doing
to start off with if you don't believe
you're going to learn the language you
won't learn it so that's tremendously
important
if you're climbing a mountain and you
don't believe you're going to reach the
top you probably won't
uh or you'll be fighting it the whole
way
you know sometimes you you have a
situation where you have screws that
turn the wrong way you're turning the
water on and
and uh
you know it
instead of turning you know to open it
instead of turning to the you know
counterclockwise the open seems to be
clockwise or whatever
if you're ever working on a screw or
trying to loosen a screw and you're not
confident that you're turning it the
wrong way you won't stay at it you'll
because you're not just not sure i mean
it's just a an example of how if you're
fighting something working on something
it's very important to believe in what
you're doing so those who believe in the
algorithm of the space repetition system
it works fine for them
i don't
i like the idea of
in language learning doing what i want
to do
if for three days in a row i want to do
nothing but read my book
then that's what i like to do if i get
keen on listening for a whole week i
don't pick up a book i only listen
that's what i want to do i'll get into
periods where i will sit at the computer
and just you know ramp up my links on
links saving a whole bunch of words to
my database that's what i want to do so
the idea that
that we do what we want to do is more
important than
feeling that you have to comply with
some
algorithm some system that requires you
to do x amount of
flash cards daily in order to not
interrupt the spaced repetition system
that's there you know
i i prefer random repetition i think
reading and listening gives me
tremendous random repetition it's not
entirely random because it's it's
determined to a large extent by the kind
of material that i'm listening to or
reading so if i pursue if i'm into
tolstoy i will get a repetition of
certain kinds of words in russian if i'm
reading economic information i'll get
other kinds of words if i want to get
modern slangy dialogue i'd go looking
for that and that would tend to repeat
itself so to the extent to some extent
you can control it but it's still sort
of a random repetition and i i like
things that are random um
the main thing that i do with with flash
carding and why i think it's so good is
aside from the fact that i'm i'm
reviewing some of these words and
phrases it also trains me to be more
attentive it makes me notice things
because when i do these flashcards i
also edit my captured phrases and i
review some of the case endings and i
become
quite you know it just develops that
ability to notice and if as i've said
many many times the key elements in
language learning are your attitude
including the confidence that you can
achieve it the time you spend on the
task and if you if you are able to do
the things that you like to do and focus
on doing things that you like to do
you're more likely to stay with it and
you're more likely to do it every day
and you're more likely to enjoy it
while you're doing it and of course the
third thing is this ability to notice
and i think random flash carding
is just as good for my ability to notice
as any effort that in my case would fail
to be systematic
uh in any kind of a spaced repetition
system
uh i made some notes here so i'm gonna
check uh to see uh yeah so believing is
very important and the biggest problem
that many classroom learners have is
that they don't
believe in anything really related to
their learning they're waiting every for
everything to come from the teacher
and so uh i believe that um
you know the other problem you know all
kinds of systems for example in the
classroom the teacher wants to teach a
certain grammar point and you must learn
it now so this i think to my mind
there's a that wants to resist all of
these systems spaced repetition systems
you've got to learn the grammar now
you've got to learn these words now they
should stick now the words kind of have
a
and any rule of grammar they all have a
mind of their own
which i think is quite random
and i don't believe that that you can
nail that down i don't believe in some
of the other systems for example uh
people who who fill their anki full of
sentences
i've never done that i like words it's
words that prevent me from understanding
and if i
accumulate enough words then i can read
more and more interesting stuff and i'll
get exposed on a random basis to more
and more phrases and so rather than
spending my time filling my anki full of
sentences and reviewing them on some
schedule
i want to be able to access more and
more interesting stuff
you know you have you see these debates
on should we be learning words or
counting words we count words at length
should we count words or should we count
morphemes what's a morpheme i don't even
know what a morpheme is i know what
morphine is
i that's something that you take when
you have a lot of pain
but i don't know what a morpheme is and
i don't care
the ipa is the same way a lot of people
swear by the ipa
you know i just like the idea of
randomly listening reading attaching you
know sound to
what i'm reading
uh
in in the text and similarly when it
comes to speaking some people say you
have to speak right away
if you believe in that that's probably
going to work for you
i believe in
focusing more on understanding and and
the speaking comes along again on a
random basis when i have the random
opportunity to speak then i take
advantage of it so
i just wanted to do a little video here
on in praise of random
random repetition systems randomly doing
what you like in order to keep your
motivation up to make sure you spend
enough time at it
and if you do
you know focus on on honing your your
skills of noticing
i think you can be as effective
er
and perhaps more effective if you
believe in the random approach
that you can be at least as effective
than
a person who follows the sort of
more rigid what i consider to be more
rigid spaced repetition system i look
forward to all of the criticism that i'm
going to get thank you for listening bye
for now